what are the basics of getting a great
shot with any camera
from an iphone to dslr
yeah i mean i i suppose it's a little
bit
like your previous question about a
beautiful shot like what makes a great
shot because it's so
it's so reliant on context so
you know any type of any shot is where
is this going to
fit into the montage of images you know
so
so it's place is really more of what i
think about
but you know on a technical level
there are certain things that i will
always be careful of you know
seeing uh usually you want to see unless
there's a reason you don't but
seeing an actor's eyes is important or
at least one
eye because we we i think as humans we
connect to eyes
even if you take googly eyes and you put
them on
you know a fork suddenly you can bond
with that fork like it suddenly has
human characteristics so i think eyes
are a big thing
to i don't think about that consciously
but i know
when i'm looking at a shot i'm shooting
figuring out where the eyes are and can
you see them
and are there other things in a frame
that are drawing your eye
as opposed to an actor's face you know
that's a big part of it so
i think maybe the way i'd put it is
i want to know in a shot where do i want
the audience to look
and how do i want them to feel when they
look there
and so if you have a big wide shot and
there's an
actor somewhere but there are other
elements in the frame
like a big turquoise teddy bear
or a big shiny something or other
i want to make sure and maybe that helps
the scene
maybe that helps the shot but i need to
know what a shot
is intended to do the ideal is
and then i can work from there and
often you end up with a frame you start
with a frame rather
where there's too much pulling the eye
and i know this shot you need to go to
that actor right away so that means we
need to knock down this wall this wall
is too bright
so let's make sure and knock this light
down so it's not hitting that wall
this you know these sometimes there's
something like an element of costume
that like oh in this shot these red
boots
are too much maybe we frame them out
maybe we
but it becomes like i guess that's
really
what it is for me is it becomes about
what's the intention and where do you
want
people to look and then you just start
almost chiseling
you you're you're like it's a sculpture
and you're trying to get rid of the
pieces that don't need to be there so
that
people are drawn to the piece be that
through
composition or lighting or color or
size and frame but i think
that would be how i would approach it
and then you know
in terms of different cameras have
different latitudes
so like a an alexa has
you know 15-ish stops of latitude so you
can have your dark to your light
but an iphone is significantly less and
if something if there's a white spot
that is blown out
there's just no information and it that
can
it can be ugly and it can
pull your eye because it's so bright and
bare so there
are technical limitations to different
sensors
and that also can be a part of it is
just something that's that's less
artistically driven and more technical
and you're like well
this this camera the sensor is going to
break unless we knock down this light
and shoot it all within a better
latitude
but again the intention is the same it's
because you don't want them looking at
the wrong thing
and and having their mind you know drift
to something else
you you're sort of trying to be
intentional about everything within
a frame
you